map kind is signaling pathway is  associated with growth proliferation  cell division and it is also associated  with different kind of cancer the  signaling begins when the ligand binds  to the receptor tyrosine kinase which  leads to receptor phosphorylation  several adapter molecules like grb2  binds to these phosphotyrosine residues  and recruit guanosine nucleotide  exchange Factor like SOS  monomeric G proteins like Ras exchange  its GTP to get activated further it  activates kinases like RAF and in  Downstream make Arc gets activated  phosphorylated Arc moves to the nucleus  there it can interact with transcription  factors and RNA polymerase to activate  gene expression which leads to growth  survival and proliferation  subscribe for the detailed video